one of my favorite things about 2022 was
the fact that there were so many
incredible television series featuring
queer representation here are our picks
for the five best series of 2022. number
five season two of call me mother
everything about that was so theatrical
you have the most Sensational legs we
can feel the confidence from here yeah I
know I host this show and you're
probably like whatever but the truth is
the series is one of the best of 2022
because of the incredible Canadian drag
artists it's diversity we haven't seen
in a drag reality competition before
anywhere in the world add in three drag
icons Miss peppermint Crystal and
Barbados as mentoring mothers Dragula
winner Landon cider and the legendary
fahrenheit as judges and you have a
series not to miss number four love
Victor the third and final season of
Love Victor once again tackle queerness
and race and the final season I know so
sad wrapped up these character stories
so beautifully for its Die Hard fans I
caught up with the cast and chatted
about the legacy of the series it's
gonna take a lot to top this this is a
cool project and has really changed my
life in so many ways like I I'm just so
grateful for it what has been the best
part of being part of a series like love
Victor as an actor it's like it's hard
to book an acting job and then when you
book one as special as this that really
uh makes an impact and connects with
people and you know like we hear from
I've been hearing so much from
um like lgbtq youth who you know they
feel seen and they they love the show
and they really connect to it it's
really beautiful that's the power of
representation all right number three on
our list High School this one no yes
what is this a business
Sarah
Tegan and Sarah doesn't even rhyme your
parents blew it The Coming of Age series
adopted from Tegan and Sarah's Memoir is
set in Calgary in the mid 90s and
follows the twins as they find their own
identities I chatted with Tegan and
Sarah who told me they found the stars
of the series on Tick Tock I know that
they were found on Tick Tock which is
incredible and life-changing for them
but who was scrolling Tick Tock I mean I
was doing the Doom scroll like we all do
before bed a little self-soothing and um
and a clip from Raley's Tick Tock showed
up but the video I saw was of her giving
a tour of her car and it was just it was
like watching me in high school oh first
I have this thing and my phone just sits
up there with a magnet right I sent it
to Sarah and I said she's a twin like go
deep like check out all these videos and
then Sarah sent them to the high school
friends because we were like is this
crazy or like is this kind of cool like
did we just luck out and find identical
twins that kind of see him like us in
high school make sure you check out High
School alright number two Chucky no
matter what he's gonna come for us again
oh I hate that doll
the second season of the hit series took
grotesque to the next level and it
didn't spare on queerness either I
caught up with the Stars who spoke about
the weight of representing the lgbtq
plus Community having a show like Chucky
represent the queer Community is
incredibly important and impactful for
so many people including myself I wish I
had a show like Chucky growing up what
kind of weight does that carry for you
it does carry a lot of weight because it
is a community that deserves just such
recognition and
um I was really happy I got to be part
of this show because there's a lot of
things that people can empathize with I
think the best parts of my day are when
I receive messages from people who have
told me how much the show's helped them
and how much they felt seen and it's
just it's awesome and number one for our
pick for the best queer series of 2022
drum roll please
Heart Stopper I I still like girls but
um
the critically acclaimed series follows
Charlie and Nick who discover their
unlikely friendship may be something
more as they navigate school and Young
Love now we're gonna tell people yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
the series was a massive success
worldwide for showing the highs and lows
of queer Youth and thankfully it's been
renewed for a second and third season
and we can't wait